il faut mettre fin au chaos migratoire
parce que le chaos migratoire ça n'est
pas une chance pour la France parce que
nos capacités d'accueil sont totalement
dépassées mais ça n'est pas non plus une
chance pour les migrants tout simplement
parce que on n pas de quoi les loger on
n pas de quoi les accueillir dignement
et enfin on sait parfaitement qu'il y a
désormais un lien entre ce chaos
migratoire et l'insécurité et cet en
sauvagement on sait que une partie de
l'immigration il participent les
Français le savent ils attendent des
politiques que on reprenne la main on
reprenne la maîtrise de nos frontières
et aussi des instruments juridiques
qu'on a abandonné dans le temps pour
maîtriser ces
frontières l'idée pour nous est de
donner à la France une vraie politique
migratoire de sortir du scénario au fil
de l'eau pour définir une vraie
stratégie cette stratégie c'est moins
d'immigration régulière meilleure
intégration et le respect des valeurs de
la République et une connaissance du
français qui soit de de bon niveau mais
c'est aussi la lutte avec beaucoup de
fermeté contre l'immigration illégale
c'est le sujet quasiment fondamental
c'est pour ça que dans le texte nous
instaurons un principe un principe
simple il n'y aura pas de visa donné aux
pays étrangers au pays sources s'il n'y
a pas en contrepartie de laisser passer
consulaire il faut effectivement établir
aussi un rapport de force avec ces pays
parce que sinon nous ne serons pas
respectés l'enjeu c'est celui-ci par
exemple quand on obtient aussi le statut
de réfugié bien sûr qu'on reste en
France mais quand on ne l'obtient pas on
doit partir il faut que la décision
définitive vaille obligation de quitter
le territoire
national si on ne maîtrise pas les flux
on ne maîtrise pas l'accueil on ne
maîtrise pas l'intégration et on
maîtrise tout simplement pas le respect
de la loi française pour permettre une
meilleure maîtrise de l'immigration il
faut d'abord commencer à faire ce que
font un certain nombre de pays dans le
monde c'est-à-dire fixer un nombre
d'étrangers que nous sommes prêts à
accueillir en France ça se fait dans le
cadre d'un débat au Parlement qui fixe
tout simplement des quotas d'arrivé en
France d'étranger ensuite il y a
d'autres facteurs qui consiste à rendre
peut-être plus compliqué d'accès à un
certain nombre de titres pour assurer de
meilleures garanties notamment
d'intégration à ceux qui viennent on
parle du regroupement familial euh on
parle aussi du titre étranger malade euh
nous avons aussi décidé de rendre moins
attractif un dispositif qui est l'aide
médicale d'État l'aide médicale d'État
c'est la sécurité sociale des
clandestins de ceux qui ne bénéficient
pas de titre de séjour pour rester en
France nous l'avons transformé en aide
médicale d'urgence qui signifie très
clairement que l'on soigne les gens qui
ont besoin de soins urgents mais qu'on
leur Prodi pas toute une panoplie de
soins qui existe jusqu'à maintenant
l'aide médicale d'État aujourd'hui c'est
plus de 400000 bénéficiaires et plus
d'un milliard d' au frais du budget de
l'État et nous estimons que nous devons
la
réduire